at the end of the day you know i'm happy to
you know be in it and uh you don't have ice
how do you know i have ice cream we don't you've
never had ice cream our fridge is from the 1980s
how do you know why do you need ice i was
going to make another cocktail yeah then i
i yeah well you keep let me just because i
you know i'm not drinking a vodka hot soda
yeah how do you not have [ __ ] hold on no no
i feel like i learned everything
i need to know about you guys
when you wake up and you want to
drink you just go i guess i'll have
lukewarm water yeah okay so
well here's a little note stop
friend just stop friend i want you i want to
stop you in your tracks right now okay okay
we have um rituals that we have in this house
okay and what you're implying three tools rituals
all right all right let me say this yeah i'm
trying can you make this quick i want to use this
all right my girlfriend and i right we love
cold beverages oh really yeah yeah yeah
can you put everything in the [ __ ]
refrigerator yeah yeah i can't believe
you don't like that do you realize that
would be a game changer but we're also
whoa dude i don't like the way you
said that yeah she's asian dude
um she's just mixed with a little bit of
french the other part bobby he's half egyptian is
that for real half filipina i love egyptians i'm
amanda med shout out to you my friend wherever
you are whatever desert you're hanging out in
right now he's in the middle east by the
way i'm not saying that as a racist thing
he's actually out in abu dhabi or something
so whatever desert you're in not a racist
thing um god bless you and take care okay this
should be an interesting cocktail someone want
to go to my sister's house and get ice is it far
it's a block away you know i'll tell you another
thing is is that we just don't use ice because i
don't drink you know that right no but you drink
fluids yeah yeah yeah but you know we so we what
we do is this okay just hear me out okay what
we do is we buy a bottle of water like this okay
yeah and then we stick it in the refrigerator the
refrigerator i don't know if you know how it works
but you start making ice maybe yeah it chills
are you sure there's no ice in there there's no
eye sweetening we've never had ice we haven't made
ice in five years yeah do you understand yeah that
half of your listeners right now are going hold on
you guys don't have i like that's like when you
finally get it it feels like such a treat like
when i go to my sister's house it's the art of
withholding she's from the philippines so when
i go get to my sister's house my the first
thing i go to is her crushed ice ice machine
yeah i can't even say that yeah you've never seen
the most delicious thing ever and i sit there and
i just crunch ice for like hours all right yeah
yeah you know you can have that every day right
yeah yeah bobby there is actually i bought all
of them i love ice i've had i've had like three
different ice makers yeah i'm thinking about
getting one installed in my garage because
i want the hardcore like the crush crush
ice right the sonics but what does ice do
it makes this drink science science science
what it is this is that what i'm saying is that
i know when you put ice in things it waters
it down or makes it cold it just makes it cold
yeah yeah if you drink it quick enough it's
cold so that your tongue doesn't go hot that
tastes like vomit vodka okay i can't believe
i i can't believe i gotta drink this quickly
yeah i'm gonna get [ __ ] hammered on this podcast
cause i'm trying to taste the ice yeah yeah let
me just say this okay next time you come over
i'm bringing my own ideas no no no no i don't
trust you yeah yeah i don't trust you that much
oh that's a challenge because let me say this
right now i'm a man of my word okay okay hear me
everyone back back up all right let me say this
right now [ __ ] you will have varieties of advice
have like eyes with different like cold grapes
oh we can freeze them yeah no
you or water you can freeze water
we don't have the ice ice maker thing cubes the
trees do we get one of those you don't even have
ice maker trays if we had an ice maker tray we'd
make ice [ __ ] nothing but look it's the old
one they are they're getting our friends with that
fridge freezer top regular what's cold in there uh
oh yeah we might have something there we might
have something there yeah go get it yeah yeah
blueberries how old are these blueberries uh
they're pretty new they're pretty new yeah
they might be a little frostbitten though
so good luck yeah yeah i'll take it you're
gonna put frozen blueberries in there something
though i also have frozen coffee oh my goodness
this is why he would win a race warrior that's
insane race wars this is what you're doing
it's as cold yeah all right and flavored
yeah this might be the new thing so ridiculous
right there all right enjoy your beverage
that's not that bad actually oh really yeah it's a
little blueberry hint that's actually really good
right i know that jim norton is now doing
a podcast for ufc right with matthew and
yeah and i'm a bigger fan than david spade
i'm a bigger fan than probably jim norton
and i did they don't give me nothing shogun
was there too what you don't even listen to
listen to me right now man i know you said
it yeah yeah i'm pouring my heart out i know
i'm sorry i'm sorry no no no and then you go
shogun was there where what was shogun yeah yeah
look at me okay this is what's going
to stop with you and i mm-hmm when i'm
talking to my brother he won't be looking at
me and he'll have be having a conversation
he already knows with an invisible entity steve
i know so i'll be like hey steve what'd you think
of that movie and my brother would have his head
turned looking at something else going hey man
don't do that to me man i'll be like yeah yeah
and you'll have a conversation with somebody else
i see you talking to yourself but i i don't
know if you're psyching yourself up or if you're
actually hearing voices no he's putting himself
in situations yeah i come up with scenarios
in his head scenarios and i live it out
unfortunately when i'm talking every time
every time so it's like he's not listening he
just did it too yeah shogun was there yeah but
i was just talking anyway it's fine i'm sorry and
that's okay you're never gonna get i'm listening
i totally want to i just don't know what that is
okay because i don't want to bobby i'm telling you
i'm alright i don't i i i no no no no no no no no
no no i don't cut me off don't don't shut me down
and go you don't have to do it you don't have to
do it because that's you being fearful you don't
want to hear the end of what i'm saying oh [ __
] this one this guy wants to get confrontational
yeah i'll get caught you want to get
confrontational you want to get give a [ __ ] do
you want to get real i'll paint myself like a
[ __ ] orca and swim in the shark and festival
i'll go mystique i'm not afraid i'll go mystique
you're not going mystery maybe a jellyfish
go inside the ocean hole you're gonna get so
transparent people can see right ocean horns
uh anyway yeah i'll do i want to do more live [
__ ] i'm honestly i i have been very fortunate
enough to be busy and out of town shooting
a lot yeah yeah yeah so and i'm what are
you working on now that's all that people can
watch i'm the new batman you're the new batman
yeah yeah uh no what i got i got a couple films
coming out uh what are they well the burning woman
there's one uh there's a oh i'm in super troopers
too oh yeah yeah that's coming out myself tyler
levine and hayes mccarthy you know hayes i
love tyler oh you guys work together i love
me tyler and hayley i love those guys yeah too
mccarthy oh i love all three of you the three of
us are uh our evil mounties we're the bad guys oh
that's [ __ ] amazing and uh and rob lowe is the
mayor of a fictitious canadian town oh wow did
you work with rob yeah yeah nice very nice guy
handsome huh yeah it's handsome as [ __ ] yeah
yeah 64 years old i mean i [ __ ] believe that
you must sleep in a hyperbaric chamber yeah uh
and uh yeah so i got a couple of you know filmy
films uh coming out we're doing another season
of the show i did last year called loudermilk
which is ron livingston and myself oh that was
good yeah yeah and i'm doing this and that and
that this and i'm ending up on things i'm going
off to shoot a film uh in a about a month here
um that we're shooting in georgia and and yeah
but i would love to do forget it i love stop it
that's what you forget what it does forget [ __ ]
gets me all investigated what do we have time wise
what do we got time wise i don't like his energy
what is the time now an hour oh we're done
hey i'm gonna be in branson um the way we end
our show is we're not ending your [ __ ] show yet
hey i'm the captain of this [ __ ] oh yeah yeah
okay i love you so much i love you too i'm a
with my little sticker whale
puffer fish in my where am i
oh i was loved and you're like oh
that looks like you're a pasty fisher
um unhelpful advice nobody gives a [ __ ] in
your audience to hear about what i'm doing
live anyway right anyway oh well you know
what bobby i'm just gonna [ __ ] hold on
do it i'm telling you something yeah and you're
gonna listen because i was nice to you at night
go ahead tell me i was nice and and all those
people didn't even bother to hang out with you
and i hung out with you right remember that
one time we went down to long beach because
a buddy of mine wanted to meet a girl oh yeah
that was i remember that oh that was terrible
yeah we were good buddies to him too we just went
down to long beach did you support him because he
wanted to see about a girl what was the black guy
that used to hang out with belle bottoms all the
time yeah yeah sean sean man yeah he was cool uh
and uh it was different time than i did and then
one time you invited me to a halo tournament
at your house yeah you weren't into that i
wasn't into that didn't play halo no he wasn't
in his 40s yet wasn't playing video games hello
good night everybody thanks for listening to tiger
belly i'm will sasso how many brothers and sisters
are there three brothers and one sister and
they were all there obviously yeah everyone just
devastated yeah because i know that i know
that i know that your brother the one that i
met the warlock uh how is he awarding what
did he call him there's something magical
about him he's like from a different like he's
from doctor strange oh like he could he can do
and um you haven't met him you don't know
he has a little [ __ ] ring thing and the
eye necklace and then the
cape oh [ __ ] yeah and so um
but what i'm saying is that he didn't
have a relationship right right with
them either right exactly remember that yeah
i do i do remember that's why i just said it
i remember yeah yeah and so i mean did all
the kids have that kind of relationship with
their parents at that point no no when
you have five kids you have different
relationships with your kids okay yeah i
mean this is the way you just talk to me
i just don't like when people talk to me
like that where do you fall are you um
i'm sorry are you scolding me and
like that's fine i don't know where
you're going through a hard time yeah yeah okay
thank you can you see it a different way though
let's rewind yeah rewind it to save it in
a different way when you have five kids one
i think when you have five kids that's better
so much better you treat them differently
don't you think so yes where are you where
are you from in california oh it's so um
so some of your some of your siblings were had
a communication that you didn't have and whatnot
yeah where do you fall i'm the second oldest okay
but my parents never wanted a girl i don't know if
your parents were cool with you being a girl no my
mom definitely wanted boys but it turns out i have
a six foot tall sister who is like basically like
we both look like linebackers so she was fine with
it and she put us always like in sports and stuff
so that was her way of coping with having girls
so you're not like a frail little girl you
could take care of yourself yeah and beat up
your boyfriend if he doesn't take care of you
exactly yeah well exactly oh let me punch him
go ahead
here's the story a long time ago many years ago
right there was a guy named will sasso that's you
okay okay and he's not fat he's thick that's you
thank you you're welcome it's a true story so far
yeah yeah keep going big dick big dick will that's
what everyone called yeah that's what everybody
whale sticker fish dicks right and um
he knew a guy by the name of italian guy
right crystalia right not a medallion he's not
an italian no he's half he's have italian a half
italian he's got the italian name right and a
kind of good-looking intrinsically funny guy
by the name of brian callan who used to work for
mad and that's how you kind of know him too right
as the beginnings of it right and at that time
their careers were okay they're you know they're
coming up you know brian's rebuilding
he had his own podcast and he decides to
you you know just we're [ __ ] what are you
talking about no not you coming up was coming up
oh yeah before whitney right when did that happen
before whitney yeah so he was coming back whitney
happened right away uh while we were doing the
podcast exactly 2012 i understand i'm just going
to i'm paving the story yeah all right but to say
no well he's not here to defend himself it doesn't
matter because he'll listen to this later internal
stuff come up to me both of these guys will come
up to me and i'll go no they're not gonna listen
to this that's that's oh they do [ __ ] listen up
don't [ __ ] listen to it and that's another
lie in your [ __ ] time story time story time
story time oh god tell the story story time i
need a second story all right oh god i'll just
point out the inaccuracies while you're having to
breathe everybody well anyway we got a guest too
so it's not about us sometimes yes it's about a
guest that um i've been looking forward to having
and also um dreading at the very same time she
is sort of like um what a laugh she's a family
she's family but also an enemy but also love
there's a lot pure love that but pure love that's
how families are it's really difficult to love
family that's true and we have esther coo here
so give her a round of applause everybody and also
i've known esther i think i first saw esther on
last comic standing oh [ __ ] somebody
said hey you're gonna see this korean chick
so i think i youtubed it or whatever and you told
a very funny joke about barack obama's name and
your mom whatever saying it and i go oh she's
really funny and um i felt like i was really
nice to you when we first met no or how did we
first meet you were always so nice to me i know
that's real okay just say it again though you
are always so nice to me first of all yeah okay
well before i even met you you heard about me
of course i knew who you were legend mad tv
legend from watching you on mad tv and
not only that but my little brother
yeah we would always make fun of him
because he looked like you oh really
and so um our family we would all laugh oh
that's nice yeah and then um because then
i thought everything was cool between us and then
you try to start a war with me oh [ __ ] on online
well you tried to start a war with me i remember
you said that she doesn't date asian men
yeah so you you know without even knowing much
more about her you just assumed she didn't date
asian men no i already write do you date asians
well that's what my joke was about that you had
a problem with on last comic standing and then
you were bitching about me on opie and anthony
and then they all started making fun of you
and norton was like she's hilarious because
you were like yeah she can't go around and
dissing asian guys and they're like why not
this was my bad no but i [ __ ] up no no no
why no i apologize when i'm in the wrong i'll
apologize no it was great because then you went
on there exposure it's exposure for both of us is
yeah at the end of the day you know my god
instinct was right about like twitter beef is the
greatest thing you can possibly do to your career
yeah you should have just kept going with it you
really should have like blown it up right some
more but i did oh yeah like korean wars you know
let's see you you're a great
you're spaghetti bolognese
i mean everyone can cook
spaghetti no no don't play
pretty it in fact do you put carrots in it no
i don't know vienna sausage yeah i put carrots
in one you do yeah is it good that way you're
supposed to i put carrots down are you supposed
to yeah carrots yeah yeah just as a base you mean
like a mirepoix wait how do you stew down carrots
you should do it down with celery and onion
to make a mirepoix but how do you i don't
know what mirepoix is is that in harry potter
it's a dance group hey everyone we're mirepoix
we're all filipino do you does that mean they boil
it they just stew it down to create like they boil
the base yeah yeah yeah why don't you do that [
__ ] i do it i know that i can't get wow i can't
get no mirepoix on my [ __ ] belly noise i can't
[ __ ] with carrots in my [ __ ] or what i do with
other stuff when i make you other stuff like the
not on and all that stuff next time you make what
else do you make um i make a lot of stuff for
myself because i cook a lot of filipino dishes
and he doesn't really he doesn't like filipino he
doesn't like good um he doesn't like yeah like i
don't know what it is cook with a lot of vinegar
all the time so oh yeah maybe he's not into it
maybe you should cook him some like real down-home
filipinos caldereta yeah like i would love to be
all right it's all right you're so angry i'm not
angry let me say something right you're so angry
that you have one taste it's like bulgogi and
then it's like without boner with bone in a pot
on fire let me say something right now let me
say something to you no no i'm tired of you no
no i'm [ __ ] on my mind i'm tired of you no i'm
tired of you i'm part of you accusing me of not
having taste i have a plethora i have a plethora
of tastes yeah tell me what's your favorite one
let's be real that's the taste
right it's about a little child
yeah but when you see a girl with a guy like i
have to let me ask you this in this town if you
saw be real if you were at a restaurant in long
beach whatever i'm out of town oh yeah because
i used to live in long beach right right and you
saw her walk into a restaurant holding the hands
of another guy yeah would you tell me yeah
for sure what if it was another guy you knew
but you were also friends with yeah if it was
crystalia not that he would right no that's not
gonna say jason collings because he lives in
long beach yeah jason is right jason collins
right he's a comic friend i love jason
i love this i want to know what you love
right yeah and he you're at a restaurant he's
holding hands with kalila right would you tell me
yeah yeah yeah i don't like that but
would you tell jason that you told him
this is tough yeah what do you do you're loyal
to both people right so if jason would do please
don't tell him it'll ruin my career you know he'll
he'll you know i mean it's not going to be good
for me dude i'll never see her again i would
ask around and pull people and see what even
the engineering is coming out yeah i would ask a
lot of guys what they would do and then you man
yeah you tell me all right [ __ ] you man you [ __
] tell me dude there's your [ __ ] pole are you in
a [ __ ] poll where you're gonna call five [ __
] people you're gonna call our agent you piece
of [ __ ] you [ __ ] tell me all right i'll tell
you no no don't don't all right [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
because let me tell you something right
now if haley was walking in with dalia
or i i don't keep saying i know why did
he want another friend of what we know
uh like michael noche oh [ __ ] i'll rap magdalena
[ __ ] that guy um brent brent uh-huh what's his
brand um yeah [ __ ] right i would pull bren aside
write that in there and go hey haley are you still
singing for him yeah brent dude dude i go i have
to tell him i'm sorry i have to tell him or you're
going to tell him i'll give you a day i'll give
you 24 hours right that's it and i expect everyone
in this room to do the same from this [ __ ]
scarlet wench okay do you mean to say harlot or
carlos i like scarlet wedge though yeah all right
you know he's good my birthday last week he he
texted me happy birthday you didn't but it's fine
did you and he spit in my face don't go lateral
on this don't go lateral let's talk about
[ __ ] anything from you but i give you stuff i
know you do you really do you're a good guy now
didn't i let you go through my water bottle
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i let you go through
the water bubble you have to feel it and i'm about
to eat some of your wage yeah you can have it yeah
i got your meat over there yeah yeah
is it a classy place your restaurant
yeah it's classy what do you mean it's it's clean
it's clean you're like you're an investor you're
an investor in that yeah yeah big time is it
off of the strip or where is it off the street
let's promote it what's it
called it's called jokoy's place
no oh god oh be real is that what it's called
it's called yo yo jay yeah oh that's cool yeah
that's awesome so it's it's off the strip it's
right by my mom's place she lives out like out in
summerland area she worked there it's a nice area
my mom works there she really she helps out well
she slices meat oh that's amazing yeah yeah cool
and then i tell her to leave when the the meats
so this is you have enough stock you can go home
this is a family run establishment my mom does not
work there [ __ ] no why would i why would i have
my mom's slices at the age of 71. you [ __ ] dick
she's retired okay she walks in like this
demarco sorry free food she does when her son
uh uh i'm sorry so sorry i'm gonna stand up again
yep take a stand that up all right take a stick
take a knee take a deep [ __ ] [ __ ] sucker let
me say something like okay yes your fake tooth
that's what you [ __ ] i don't i know i am
i want to tell you something right now right
yes there's a place called um what's the house
in little tokyo yeah it's the most successful
[ __ ] shabbos place in la and the parents work
that right the guy that owns it works slices the
meat there yes because he didn't so i saw anybody
yeah but i'm just telling you when you said it i'm
like okay i could believe that you [ __ ] no no no
there's a difference between that family and mine
you want to know the difference yeah that guy has
to [ __ ] work there that's his paycheck whoa my
mom's retired you know what i would [ __ ] [ __ ]
you let me say this mom thanks for giving birth to
me and you know what on your 70th birthday you're
hired go [ __ ] slice meat i wish you know what i
wish upon you now you know what i wish upon you
only one week at this comedy club side but let
me say something right now you're just like this [
__ ] nut all right you don't watch game of thrones
it's [ __ ] silly all right it's a cultural
phenomenon eric i i i hear nothing talk in the
mic you [ __ ] not so far yeah yeah [ __ ] you no
no no no angry don't get angry that's how i talk
sorry don't smash i've heard nothing but good
things about it but uh i'm just so far behind
yeah okay and i i like when i watch shows like
that i'd like to binge watch them all right so how
long would it take for me to start from episode
one all the way through that's what my best friend
can i just say this no i am so envious that you [
__ ] martin fink you guys haven't seen it because
if i was in your thing i'd be so excited i go
oh my god the next three weeks are gonna be the
most amazing three weeks of my life that's how
good the [ __ ] show is back to back yes so um
what is that you know what and you're getting
like a little your adrenaline flowing and you're
looking at me like i'm clay guido i'm not all
right i'm your friend you're clay guido whatever
whatever that old man's name is okay let me say
this right now okay whatever you're going through
right now the adrenaline you want to smash
my head the back of your [ __ ] check that
[ __ ] because let me say something right now
i'm a rage monster too what does that mean i'll
tell you what that means i'll tell you what
that means chachi okay all right i have um
hrs oh you know what that is i have no idea
hidden [ __ ] strength oh you don't think that
people with that [ __ ] or chimpanzees are
strong but they'll break maybe you shouldn't
compare retards to chimpanzees no in terms
of strength those are very strong animals
my bite's like a hyena is that do i feel bad
about that no all right your face is like
wow shots fired and you know what
that's a spreadsheet right there
what's the tally right now what that's like nine
spreadsheets all right [ __ ] i'm gonna tell you
right now dude all right so relax we're good you
and i we're friends all right and also on top of
it i'm not afraid of you and also on top of that
right now is that that's not what happened what
happened i respect you and i love you and
i'm always going to be on your corner dude
boom so i have another thing that i'm concerned
about i'm going to just read you something
okay jesus no don't do that don't check with my
publicist first so you the other last week you go
bobby it's joe cool just bobby there's personal
[ __ ] there's nothing there i'm not going to
read the whole thing i would just read this
bobby it's joe i'll edit this out if you
don't want it no you won't yeah i sort of got
it well you don't even have a proper episode
we're surrounded in sanrio i said i feel like
we're [ __ ] are you okay and you go we're better
now are you really concerned yeah jerk how are
you that's [ __ ] rude yeah well you are a piece
of [ __ ] no you are people you want to see my
face you want to see concerned you want to see
my sir well i'm going to i'm going to do this
okay i'm going to give you a face concern go
see you're joking around with that
even right there that was good
let me do it again one more time i swear to god
your concern looks like you're
holding it in your own shirt
just hold on let me try all
right i'm gonna say are you okay
you don't care see no you don't care give me
a shot give me a shot that's why i asked you
all right that's why i asked
you are you concerned i don't
are you okay no no no no that's even i think he
does that i don't think he does that yeah yeah who
says do stuttering to make you saying your idea
of things to do that's one thing dude yes yes
yeah yeah i'm gonna tell you something right
now my friend okay there's only a couple of
things in life that you need all right shelter
food and sexualities hey all right clothing i'll
[ __ ] do this all day all right bobby i don't
give away stop it all right stop my point isn't
this scratching it is that yes food is a big one
it's another thing all right three in the morning
i can't sleep i feel dirty should i take a bath
or can i go to a steam room a really cool korean
bath house this is like some first world problem [
__ ] right yeah that's what i'm saying is that i'm
not saying listen i know that in an apocalyptic
situation right we're all [ __ ] not me you maybe
that's it that and this is this is why this is why
we're here right now because that right there is
provocation is that the right word provocation
you just provoked me i also just wanted uh no
just let me just finish this okay so in a
zombie apocalypse right right that you think
you would live longer than me come on come
on come on let's just be do you have hunting
do you have hunting skills i've i have hunting
skills i mean i'm gonna sweet i'm an athlete
here's the thing if we could both hide but if i
get caught i could actually do something about
it and get away no you can't call a zombie
and then all of a sudden you're you know man
you're trying to tie kick zombie kick people that
would be awesome it doesn't have to be that but i
for for example i can run faster than you can i'm
sure yeah i don't need a run dude i'm an event
you're gonna live an event yeah that's where
you know where i'm gonna go i'm gonna go to
the mall well this goes back to the food
what are you gonna do i'm gonna go to west
covina mall already i haven't planned out what
happens when you know this is your plan yeah
and i'm gonna hide in a van and then all of a
sudden i'm gonna like every day i'm gonna like
lock each door i'm gonna try to kill all the
zombies inside then i would lock all the doors
and i would eat like a um hot dog on a stick
all day okay so what happens about the other
people sounds like dead other people that that
are still alive that you you can join me if you
want to but well no you'd be joining me i'd
be running the show see that's i don't want
to sleep so wait who is that you know what's
up i'm sorry you want him to bend the knee
i'm not going to bend the knee okay how do you
establish alpha you know what you're like the
[ __ ] what was that guy the mayor or whatever
that was in walking dead what's his name governor
the governor of the governor you're the governor
you're the bad guy oh wow i'm the good guy you're
right my clan we farm we love each other you and
enslave that's fine but but rick's also a badass
what do you want me to do
you know what he would do
you know what i know him yeah
you know me are the only humans alone this
dude would [ __ ] try to [ __ ] me no wait you
the only the only asian comics that i saw that
that inspired me because i was so into comedy
was margaret cho and like henry cho i can't even
remember the ones that i could see like on like on
cable you know that were coming on frequently
and then when i went to la jolla because this
comic got me he knew the manager there and got
me on and i saw bobby lee my head blew up i was
like oh my god cause i was weird-looking no you
were funny you're you're a korean you know what
i mean you were like you were you were like yo
this is what was your first impression of me uh
i thought you had no i don't want to say it yeah
yeah that was [ __ ] no down like yeah a little
bit of that [ __ ] you know what dude but a lot
of people say that no no a lot of people say i
know that one people in the community a lot of
people say i know but when they say it it really
i don't know why you're laughing george okay
because in terms of whites you're like a two jesus
that's out of a hundred that's a lot of rights
you're the worst you're like you you you're worth
worthless god okay if you want them to you want
them to stay around and work for you and he has
syndrome no one is left premium talk show first
of all did you really believe that i was [ __ ] i
thought you know that's like joke that is a
joke let me answer the question yeah go ahead
sorry can i explain myself yeah
go ahead because they don't know
they only know good looking bobby
with the good rock and roll hair
and the missing tooth they only know that guy
they only know good looking rock and roll bobby
hot hot rock and roll chick yeah that's all they
know yeah yeah you know what i mean missing tooth
cat hair cat hair and beanie like they only
know that one yeah onesie shirt onesie shirt
all right that's all they know i know bobby hole
hawaiian shirt and your aqua and and used to do
let me explain why i thought you had down syndrome
okay go ahead god yeah yeah let me explain like
i'm not just trying to be funny i know i know
you really we all i thought you had difficulty
really hurting my feelings okay no really bobby
can i explain okay so we go to la jolla yeah
and the guy the mc goes oh my god this kid
killing it out here you know what i mean
he's we got to hurry up because his boss is up
and then they go bobby lee everybody crowd goes
crazy he's a local favorite right and then he
does this thing where his eyes are kind of like
yeah cause he was kind of doing a stoner
thing yeah yeah then he had this big like
hair and then he'd move his head yeah and
it took him forever to get to the microphone
yeah and i thought oh he's he's special yeah
yeah but you know what that's called mugging yeah
i was [ __ ] mugging for the crowd you [
__ ] piece of [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah
but i would go up there right i would mess up
my hair and you know what my opening line was
what i'm not really asian i just woke up yeah
two minute applause break crushed standing off
standing up no i'm not even joking two minutes a [
__ ] applause break i stood yeah how that's at the
[ __ ] first place that was mirage yeah and then
you did you did uh dolphins tears i did dolphins
and tiger [ __ ] yeah it made it the mirage yeah
you had a shovel who was it zigfried and roy's
i had to no i had to clean siegfried's in order
to play with the dolphins oh right yeah he said
yeah i did you didn't meet zigfried
yeah secret always came through roy
never came through oh really is he
nice secret was is so funny because
when you look at i don't know if anyone
gives a [ __ ] that's listening yeah
but people don't know that people don't
know [ __ ] people don't know that uh
mark wahlberg was [ __ ] marky mark [ __
] that's true you called me a gift to them
i don't care anyway sorry you're
trying to act like this is a premium
[ __ ] talk show you got a camera
got a cameraman in a goddamn car
all right i apologize economic collapse of you
know 708. so then you couldn't really get into
these anyway it was very it's a great house i was
very fortunate you know i regret even asking it
that's not a really good way to you know
what bobby i'm going to tell you something
you know i'm going to tell you was okay we
should end it there yeah yeah yeah because
just like you said you did some 10-minute podcasts
and it inspired you to move forward yeah perhaps
it even happened anyways thanks will south coming
by everyone clap right now they're not we'll stop
for coming by they're not all cut it off they're
not all home runs cut it off sometimes people
just want to what eddie shows bobby yeah i'm
at the end of the stereo emperor i just want
to know about the ontario improv this weekend
you want to hear about remember check it out
i'm also planning to hear about allison emperor
did you get when you get those papers in right
and i want to oh i understand brian ortega for
killing him you know someone who does you watch
mma you know someone who does uh brick work [ __
] he bit he cuz it'll improve the frankie edgar
that's really gonna bring up the resale value of
your house yeah yeah it's now never a bad idea to
put it in another bathroom beat max holloway never
a bad idea i don't know that i didn't know you got
the crew there already you might as well have them
come in that would be a really good thing i've got
peg and groove hardwood that's been standing at
once sitting underneath it was centered underneath
marble everybody that was a great hey take a claw
hammer take it to some of your uh off right now
some of you some of your floors you might find
some very expensive wood under there on instagram
at the tiger belly anything that you think that
someone would take out and put in another house
that's what you're looking for in your
property don't be afraid to spend the
money you're living in your investment make
sure you check out our sponsor brooklyn and
brooklyn it's hard to find a place on your own
oh sorry not brooklyn but also brooklyn and you
bought some stuff there they're brother sponsors
but two broke women yeah good to have good linens
get a couple and get a get a little cover for the
duvet too just in case things get saucy with your